[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on a qu'est ce qu'on a à
offrir en fait pourquoi est ce que les
gens qui organisent ce genre d'événement
font appel à nous qu est-ce qui
s'attendent à recevoir de nous je suis
dit ok on a oui c'est vrai on a trois
restaurants et un service traiteur mais
bon regardez il ya quelques semaines sur
sur la télé un français qui avait ouvert
un restaurant amiens et qu'un je pense
il ya cinq ans avait 35 franchise à
travers la france ont déjà heureusement
qu'il n'a pas ouvert ici sinon se
répondent en face de vous je ne serai
pas sur la carte clair et on s'est dit
ok donc c'est pas aussi spécial que ça a
c'est vrai on apprécie on sait que c'est
beaucoup de travail mais après qu'est ce
qui a donc on peut partager parce qu'on
n'est pas aussi spéciaux que ça après
tout on s'est dit ok on va se regarder
nous-mêmes et on va essayer de voir
qu'est ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce qu'on a
deux qu'est ce qu'on peut partager
qu'est-ce qu'on peut transmettre aux
jeunes et mam au moins je sais dit ok
peut-être que des gens qui nous
regardent se rendre compte que on est
peut-être déjà qu'on est con est rentré
dans un environnement socio politique
était un peu compliqué mais rentre en
2010 des etats unis quand il y avait la
guerre et tout donc déjà c'est vrai que
ça peut être compliqué après peut-être
que les gens qui nous regardent peuvent
se dire
ok l'heure
dans background leur parcours non ne les
prédestinait pas à à ce parcours parce
que christelle qui aujourd'hui des
livres dans quatre établissements au
quotidien de la cuisine américaine dans
un autre la cuisine africaine dans un
autre cuisine internationale avec des
plats taille japonais jamaïcain n'a
jamais fait d'école de cuisine culinaire
aux séries jamais n'a jamais n'a jamais
travaillé sous un grand chef et moi qui
aujourd'hui il doit dîner avec mon dieu
une équipe de directeurs financiers de
comptable et de des centrales d'achat de
ressources humaines
j'ai un bac + même pas de même pas de
deux diplômes universitaires et donc
peut-être que ces gens aussi regarder
voit que 1 travers les réseaux sociaux
on peut voir que malgré malgré tout ce
travail parce que tout le monde se dit
que la restauration prend beaucoup de
temps mais nous on a quand même
narry voir le temps pour no no no 3
enfants pour notre famille pour nos
parents pour nos amis même pour les
clubs de la ville 1
on a du temps et donc c'est vrai qu'il
ya quand même le contexte est un peu
difficile mais je pense qu'on a quand
même tous vu des des vidéos
motivationnelle à la télé sur internet
qui disent ok bah écoute et des sportifs
des champions qui ont tout gagné et puis
qui se lève après avoir gagné le super
bowl où la nfl ou la ligue des champions
leur championnat national qui disent ok
lendemain on à l'entraînement il faut
qu'on faut concentrer il faut qu'on
cartonne qu'on aille plus loin
et ben moi je pense qu'à travers ces
vidéos qu'on a tous vu il ya déjà la
réponse un beau succès nous on l'a
peut-être à notre petite échelle mais
c'est ce à quoi il faut avoir envie de
le faire tout le temps il faut être
motivé il faut faut juste travailler
quoi on peut on pourra rien dire d'autre
on pourra peut-être partager notre
histoire
et puis faire savoir comment nous aussi
on a puisé à travers ses vidéos mais je
pense que le message final sera ça c'est
pouvoir travailler longtemps en
intensément en fait
ce que je vais vous raconter là c'est
juste notre petite histoire à nous sans
que moi nous sommes rencontrés aux états
unis je travaille dans un restaurant en
tant que manager et il voulait être
faire varier le boulot mais il ya
quelques temps plus tard il est le
boulot et jamais en mentor anna cannois
qui était vraiment quelqu'un de l'âge de
mon père qui vraiment ma vue bosser en
tant qu'étudiant qui parlait pas anglais
qui veut de l'arrivée est vraiment qui
m'a vu devenir moins que serveuse
serveuse et après manager et quand je
rentrais franck et qu'on a commencé
éventuellement à travailler ensemble
c'est du moins ce que ces deux là
finalement christelle a trouvé la
personne que lui faut pour pouvoir
devenir indépendante et on n'avait même
pas 1000 $ dans notre compte et il nous
a dit bon je pense que vous êtes prêts
et ils nous en faire une restaurant de
250 mille dollars dans sa campagne 2000
femmes étudiants comme ça et ce monsieur
il avait un enfant une fille unique
mais la donne avant quoi avec lui et
tout est parti de là on a bossé pendant
cinq ans on a travaillé si on était
vraiment content nos parents nous
n'arrivons pas à croire mais vous savez
ce qu'on a fait de ce restaurant la
perte
on a tout perdu on a perdu notre maison
on a perdu notre restaurant on a perdu
nos voitures on a tout perdu
est ce qu'on s'est arrêté là non après
ça on se retrouvait tous les deux lui à
l'est de la ville - l'ouest dans le
ghetto et
dans des boulots vraiment qu'on n'aurait
jamais imaginé qu'on on aurait pu avoir
non c'est pas découragé on s'est juste
dit on a honte en stage de tout le monde
on travaille et éventuellement on va
retrouver notre vie où quelque chose et
quelques années plus tard on se retrouve
à abidjan en ouvrant notre premier
restaurant on avait la foi on s'est dit
ça va marcher et dieu merci d immoral
nous ont suivis les américains nous ont
suivis les expatriés nous ont suivis et
après on s'est dit mais peut-être que le
restaurant américain ça suffit pas pour
nom côte d'ivoire on est ivoirien de
voiture un restaurant ivoiriens et on a
faim resteront ivoiriens ont suivi les
expatriés de votre suivi les japonais de
monsieur tout le monde ensuite
et après on s'est retroussée des banques
ça suffit pas que celle a besoin de
s'exprimer dans la cuisine peut être
qu'elle veut toucher la cuisine indienne
japonaise
on a ouvert notre restaurant qui a aussi
suivi qui a marché
juste pour dire que on a connu des
échecs
non je ne s'est pas arrêté là et on ne
s'arrêtera jamais là ça fait partie de
la vie des choux et c'est normal échoué
mais est-ce qu'on s'arrête à n'annonce
jamin on va toujours continuer et puis
on se donne pas d' excuses
jamin se dit qu'il ya des gens qui le
font au chili peut-être au mozambique et
tout est donc ça veut dire qu'on peut
faire après ils le font dans des
environnement complètement différent
mais elle va le faire dans leur
environnement donc ça veut dire qu'on
peut aussi et on a peut-être
l'avantagent nous de travailler dans un
avantage que notre travail soit notre
passion mais je crois que même si on est
en même temps que le travail et la
passion n'a pas les on n'est pas
qualifié pour on n'a pas fait d'école
pour on n'est pas on n'a pas appris
avant donc on dit aussi qu'on peut avoir
le
le boulot le travail qui n'est pas la
passion et bien faire je veux dire que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui je pense que
tout le monde sera d'accord tout le
monde a besoin des meilleurs dans son
équipe quand on était tout jeune et
qu'on joue au football on mettait il y
avait deux gars de capitaines les plus
forts et après on mettait tout le monde
au milieu on choisissait en dire moi je
suis là je suis là on partait des
meilleurs jusqu'à à ceux qui sont moins
bons et donc ça veut dire que mam
conçoit caissier à mon avis ou qu'on
soit en vente du charbon
on a besoin des meilleurs on a besoin et
donc si on a énoncé sur sur quoi on
compte pour pour aller de l'avant on se
dit que tant qu'on fera tout bien c'est
à dire des sauces du steak ou d'une
sauce à poissons d'un service ou les
décors d'un resto dans les gens
viendront vers nous et on aurait
toujours de quoi pouvoir aller devant
jette il faut absolument chercher à de
meilleurs mondiaux bonne excuse j'ai ma
soeur qui est qui était professeur à
l'université pendant un moment et qui en
chimie fine une matière un peu compliqué
pour la plupart des gens et elle me
disait que ce qu'elle disait à ses
étudiants qui avaient du mal à bouger sa
matière qui voulaient dont il avait
besoin pour être un doctorat en chimie à
leur disais ok tu veux être un docteur
en chimie
pendant trente quarante ans de ta vie
mais tu refuse de te sacrifier de bosser
dur pour une matière qui durera que
quatre - de ta vie sa patronne si tu
décides de te sacrifier pour ses quatre
mois pendant 40 ans chevalier et après
ce temps qu en général à la perspective
changer un peu il se donna un peu plus
et la plupart d'entre eux et
éventuellement passer la classe c'est
juste pour dire qu'on aura toujours des
obstacles
ça ne va jamais s'arrêter mais est ce
que ça veut dire qu'on doit fléchir non
après je pense que ce que tu veux dire
c'est un peu que sur le parcours on est
obligé de faire des choses on n'a pas
envie de faire des choses qu'on n'aime
pas faire nous on aime servir à préparer
mettre les gens à l'aise aujourd'hui on
passe des heures dans des réunions
interminables pour des tests mais on est
bien obligé de les faire on passe du
temps avec des départements ressources
humaines des choses comme ça qu'on
n'aime pas du tout mais on est obligé
parce que ça fait partie de
de l'expérience des chemins on est
obligé de passer par là pour grandir
mais n'empêche que on se donne pas de
limites
on sait que pour on veut grandir on veut
on peut aller beaucoup plus loin que ça
mais il faut faire le nécessaire pour ne
pas avoir de limites quand on rentrait
nous en 2010 on rêvait d'avoir le
meilleur restaurant d'abidjan on était
fous d'ailleurs parce qu'on n'avait pas
d'argent on est venu avec des bricoles
des vieilles chaises et tout est dans la
tête on disait qu'on venait à voir le
meilleur restait complètement fou je
lancerai coup sur coup mais on est on
est arrivé on s'est rendu compte de
l'environnement
c'était compliqué mais on s'est pas
découragé et on s'est dit et dieu merci
voilà récemment en a quand même un de
nos restos qui se retrouve quand même
dans la catégorie des meilleurs
restaurants de la ville et on en est
fiers mais est-ce qu'on s'arrête là on
s'arrête pas là on continue parce que on
sait que c'est possible tant qu' on
travaille tous qui nous tous qui nous
faut aujourd'hui c'est du temps à
consacrer au travail et puis voilà et
intensément
n'empêche que on a une vie on passe
beaucoup de temps ensemble on va en
vacances en occupent nos enfants on veut
ça mais pas au prix de sacrifier notre
voilà bien sûr en fait tout ce qu'on
veut dire c'est que je pense honnêtement
que quel que soit on se trouve
le rêve est possible donc on en croit
d'ivoire le régulier possible
[Applaudissements]